[Music]
this morning on the dish chef known for
making the most of produce at its peak
Joshua McFadden grew up in Wisconsin and
fell in love with food farming and the
seasons after culinary school and jobs
at top restaurants nationwide he spent
an influential two years on a farm in
Maine there he learned how to bring out
the best in fresh produce something he
does at Portland Oregon's AVA genes and
tusks and what he teaches in his first
cookbook six seasons a new way with
vegetables which just last night won the
James Beard Award for Best vegetable
focused cookbook Joshua McFadden good
morning welcome to the dish thank you
bring out the bling it's amazing how did
you feel to win that I'm still feeling
it it's the whole thing is kind of
blowing my mind all right tell us what's
on this really spectacular table closest
to you lamb meatballs with a little
tangy kind of like a flatbread which is
really fun to make kind of like little
pitas a little beet avocado salad kind
of a classic updated it's pasta that has
snap peas in it no couscous out but has
apricots and peas it goes great with the
lamb meatballs simple chili roasted and
honey radishes and then this you would
think is young good but it's actually a
carrot pie wow it's beautiful and this
is homemade rhubarb water it is yes
Cheers
no alcohol they spent something there
for me so you are from Racine Wisconsin
you're sorry and you went to school and
I've cooked what culinary school
oh no film school at school NYC well how
did your love a food develop that's a
great question I don't know I just I
fell in love with restaurants and then I
just kind of realized that I always
loved food were you thinking you were to
be a filmmaker in the beginning I was
and then too many professors were like
what are you concentrating on what do
you cost around like I kind of
concentrated on at all and being in
restaurants I just fell in love with
this story and everything that was going
on
and deeply fell in love with food and
then just kind of took it really far and
here we are
they have really far and you really kind
of push the envelope because six season
says what I think few chefs have done in
terms of really focusing on vegetables
why they're delicious I don't know it's
just it's such a fun from the colors to
the textures to the seasons you know Vic
season six we added two more it just I
don't know just it made sense to me it
just seasonal eating and that idea is
just so fun but they will have snap peas
for the first time probably this year
right no and stuff like that is just
it's such a reward it's like a
celebration just natural it encourages
farm-to-table too we talked about this a
little before but but you spent a couple
years on the farm
I mean which turned out be incredibly
influential for you to how it completely
changed my life
well I'd moved from here actually I was
working the last restaurant I was that
was at Blue Hill and as we all know the
restaurant industry is very hard and
lots of work and it was very humbling to
see that farming is more more work and
it was also just being outside and
learning and seeing a seed go and you
know do all the things and then harvest
that cook that it was a really humbling
experience it it changed you in terms of
your approach to food but also
personally in a way personally in a way
cuz I just I was able to slow down and
reflect I've been working professionally
in kitchens for you know 10 plus years
and then at that point I just like on
this beautiful farm and swimming in a
pond and yeah you know harvesting food
and it I slowed down and figured out
what was important restaurant work is
non-stop especially if you own a
restaurant yeah yeah well we have to ask
you if you had your choice of sharing
this fabulous meal with anyone in the
world past or present living or dead who
would that person be and tell us I guess
write it well my name Rick Rubin
actually oh I love that choice Wow
that's where I would do that why I'm
obsessive music and I didn't even hear
better stories yeah he's working with
everybody you're Anthony Mason man yeah
I love that's a great choice I've won
at that dinner right yeah well you know
what chef Joshua McFadden we thank you
for being here we thank you for this
amazing food and for more on Chef
McFadden and the dish head to our
website at CBS this morning calm